Good afternoon, I welcome
you all to the third event in the
Latin American Political Leaders Series. My name is Claudia
Valeria. I am Professor of Anthropology and
Director of the Council for
Latin American and Iberian Studies at
Yale University.
Our distinguished speaker today is the
Judge Ricardo Pérez Manrique
President of the Inter-American Court of
Human Rights who will give a
presentation on human rights and
freedom of expression in Latin America'
After the presentation there will be a
conversation and everyone is invited
to join a discussion
by sending their questions in the
psuv question and answer box we are
delighted and delighted to
welcome distinguished jurist
professor claudia flores as moderator
of today's event
claudia flores is clinical professor of
law at the
university of chicago law school as well as
director of the  global
dog rights clinic  al de hielo and she is a visiting
clinical professor of law
at the college she is a visiting professor of
law at
professor flores's college of law will introduce
today's importer and moderate the
conversation
before I leave the event in your hands
I would like to say a few words about the
Latin American Political Leaders Series
This series seeks to create a dialogue on
the future of democratization,
human rights and development with
political leaders from across Latin America
and the Caribbean.
Our desire is to bring these leaders
into a
vigorous and respectful discussion on
pressing issues for the  time and at the same time
benefit benefit from years of
experience in public life
this series could not have been possible
without the generous support of george herbert
walker junior light for fun in
international studies and this event
would not have been possible without the
help and support  support of our
collaborators in the international affairs office on
foxx international scholarship program and the ice
university peace and development program
thank you very much
everyone and without further ado we
welcome professor claudia flores thank you
very much claudia but can you all
listen to me well yes ok good with
a lot  I am pleased to introduce
Mr. Ricardo Pérez Manrique, who is
the president of the Inter-American Court
of Human Rights. Today we are going to have
a very interesting conversation with him.
Mr. Manrique Pérez Manrique is a
lawyer in Uruguay and a judge of the
Inter-American Court of Human Rights.  Since
2019 he has been President and Minister of the
Supreme Court of Justice of the
Eastern Republic of Uruguay, which he has been a
member of since
2012. In 1989, he entered the magistracy
in Uruguay, completing a long career
of more than 30 years in the
Uruguayan judiciary. He was Permanent Secretary  of
the Ibero-American Judicial Summit
has been the author of various
articles and publications on
issues related to
international human rights law
protection of children freedom of
expression among other
views classes at various universities
in Latin America and Europe
graduated from the University of the
Republic with a doctorate in
rights and social sciences in 1973 in
1974 and  He also revalidated his degree at the
University of Buenos Aires, practicing his
profession in the Argentine Republic,
so with that, the Lord, we look forward to your
presentation with great enthusiasm.
Good morning to all of Asia, my
greetings to Professor Claudia Valeria,
President of the Council of
Latin American Studies and  ibéricos de yale to the
professor of clinical law at
yale university
claudia flores and thanks
agustín to ordóñez ordóñez
visiting researcher from this university who is a
graduate of the journalist program of
the inter-american court of
human rights but I will treat very briefly
for a  part of making a synthesis of
the  genesis and operation of the
inter-American system for the protection of
human rights and, on the other hand, since
talking with you about the way in which the
court has specifically developed the
right to freedom of expression
throughout its jurisprudence and with three
emblematic sentences handed down
during  In the year 2021, let's say that
the inter-American system for the protection
of human rights
is
rooted in history and
directly connected to the history of the
organization of American states, since
in
1948,
in April of that year, in Bogotá, the capital of
the Republic of Colombia, the
organization of american states and
gradually and concretely and in
parallel to the founding of the oas,
the first document of the
americas referring to human rights is issued,
which is the american declaration on
the rights and duties of this
inter-american system of protection that
is going away  perfecting over
time now we are going to develop it  r with
greater intensity
is today an example in the region but it
is also an example in the world of the
extent to which the development of a
system that protects human rights
but also has a court
specialized in the protection of these
human rights and is
important and transcendent useful from the point of
view of the life of the peoples of the
region let's say that the
historical development that you can see
there in this in this image
in 1948 the approval of the
oea charter and the adoption of the
american declaration  of rights and duties of
man, it should be noted that this declaration of
April 1948 precedes the
universal declaration on
December 10, 1948 by six months and was a source
of information for the
universal declaration in 1959 the
first institution was created  that at the regional level
applies in this case and supervises
compliance with the obligations of the
American declaration that is the
inter-American commission  ican for human rights in
1969 the american convention
on human rights or pact of san
jose de costa rica was approved and finally he 179 we
have the installation of the
inter-american court of human rights i believe
that this synthesis clearly demonstrates
how the system evolves until asia the
operation  Currently, the
American convention in the very tight
synthesis is a human rights treaty
that lists
the duties of states, basically
the duties to guarantee the rights and
freedoms recognized in the convention
without discrimination of any kind and
the need to adopt
legal provisions.  Internally, for the purpose of making
people's human rights effective, a series of
human rights is developed, among which are
civil and political rights and
also economic, social,
cultural and environmental rights in article
26 and the creation of  an
organic system of protection
Human Rights Section integrated on the one hand
by the commission that we have already seen that was
created in 1959 on
the other hand by the
Inter-American Court itself which,
as its regulations say, the
Inter-American Court is an
autonomous judicial body whose purpose and
competence  It is to apply and enforce
the American Convention on
Human Rights. This system has been developed.
The Court has been in existence for 42 years
and jurisprudence is of great
importance in the region.  On the
one hand, they carry out a thematic study of the jurisprudence of the Inter-American Court and, on the other
hand, a country-by-country study of
how the Court has
solved the cases of the
countries that are under its jurisdiction, which
are 20 in the region, ranging from
Mexico to Argentina
including the Dominican Republic and any Caribbean country
o point out
especially that I am interested in making
reference to freedom of expression
that the court has indicated is a
cornerstone for democracy I should
say that the key article of the
American convention that gives the guidelines
that the court has developed throughout
its  jurisprudence of these 42 years is
article 15 that at 13 of the
American convention that refers to
freedom of thought and freedom of
expression in this first is a right
of every person and also of
institutions freedom of thought
and expression and  On the other hand, the
definition of freedom of expression and
thought as the freedom to
seek to receive and disseminate
information, ideas of all kinds,
beyond borders and by the means
chosen, what are the conclusions that
we can draw from this, well, the court has
concluded that the right to seek
information, for example, encompasses the
need to preserve free access to
information
and on that the court  an
emblematic sentence in 2006 that the
key sentences and that profile is also the court
when grip has referred to
subsequent responsibilities and this I
want to expressly teach that the
principle that in no communication
must be subject to prior
censorship
the absolute forecast of the
Prior censorship is exclusive to the
American convention because Article 19 of the
United Nations Covenant on Civil and Political Rights does not provide for the prohibition
of censorship and is only provided for in
subsequent liability in
cases specifically
designed by the convention itself, which it
does  give us time then we
are going to talk about it then
look at what is the degree of amplitude is
of transcendence of that numeral first
because it speaks of any form of
communication via a procedure
by which it is issued which allows
any type of inconvenience to work
the solutions of article 13 for
example to the operation of the
social networks in terms of media
of ideas which acquires
a great current relevance in the face of the
challenges of communication that today
we have
in court in its prime one of its
first decisions in
advisory opinion 5 of 85 on November 13 no
85 referred to  The obligation
to police journalists says, among
other things, that a society that is not
well informed is not fully free, and
this is a basic point because the
construction of the jurisprudence of the
court and of the law as it is seen by
the court is based on the fact that  If there is no
freedom of expression, if there is no freedom
of communication, democratic debate is not possible,
and if democratic debate
is not possible,
representative democracy and the rule of law are not possible.
Therefore, the essential angle is this
freedom that I know
applies and is  suddenly in the
widest possible way under the
principle that freedom is the rule
and the restriction of freedom of
expression and  In absolute exception,
the court has said that this right
has an individual dimension, that is,
the right of each person to
freely express their opinion and express their
views on different facts of
private life, and on the other hand, the
social dimension, that is, the right
that in terms of community,
people have to know what
other people say for the precise purpose
of configuring the basic rules of the edl
of a democratic state of right
holders are all the people, the
communities, etc.
and I want to point out this that seems very
important the
inter-american democratic charter document of 2011 that is
the cornerstone that unites the three
basic concepts of
representative democracy rule of law and
respect for human rights as
basic elements of a triptych that
make up the inter-american community
establishes that they are essential elements
of democracy  representative, among
others, respect for rights  Human facts
and fundamental freedoms and
this article culminates by saying that they are
fundamental components of the exercise
of democracy and excites, among others,
freedom of expression and of the press,
that is, freedom of expression and of the
press is a fundamental element for
the exercise itself.  for the exercise of
democracy for the exercise of
democracy and for the validity of the
rule of law itself in the case of the last
temptation of cristo olmedo gustos y
otros chiles y otros versos chiles the
court determined that
censorship prior to a wing was not acceptable  to the exhibition
of this film the last temptation of
christ and as a consequence of this
sentence the state of chile changed in
the constitution that contrary to the
american convention
enabled prior censorship the cases
of the intermediate court prospered by
versus peru
points out the necessity and essentiality  for
a democratic society of the exercise
of the right to freedom of expression
in herrera ulloa versus costa rica,
the need for
democratic control by society and
the importance of journalism in
this regard are reiterated.
granier et al. carmen su venezuela, it is
said that the media are vehicles for
the exercise of the social dimension of
freedom in a  democratic society,
which is why it is essential that
the most diverse
information and opinions be collected and the court
enters into what are the different
indirect restrictions on freedom
of expression that constitute attacks
against it insofar as they prevent or
prohibit the possibility of a free
democratic debate and talks about the imposition of
criminal sanctions
taking away a shareholder's nationality
will make it non-renewal of the use of the
radio spectrum
and that the enunciation of
restrictive means is not the chat jacket and
this regarding the role of journalists
the court has highlighted  What is the
profession of journalist involves seeking to
receive and disseminate information  the
journalist is an essential actor in the
exercise of freedom of expression
as a journalist but also in the
social dimension the exercise of
journalism requires that a person be
involved in activities that are
defined or enclosed within
the freedom of expression guaranteed in
the convention errors  From the experience of the
journalist,
freedom of expression cannot be differentiated since, on the contrary,
both things are obviously
involved, since the
professional journalist is not and cannot be anything other
than a person who has decided to
exercise freedom of expression in a
stable and remunerated continuous manner and I  He
added that
this professional exercise is
the one that allows the
collective or social exercise of freedom of
expression because it is the one that allows
people to be informed and
facilitates the democratic debate
regarding the protections for
journalists. I want to point out two
sentences of stress very familiar to
their  colombia a journalist who must go
into exile because for
covering acts contrary to the
interests of the government of
power he
is persecuted the case carvajal carvajal
versus colombia is from 2018 which is the
murder of a journalist who
currently continues to go unpunished due to his
proximity  In the context of intense
political and armed violence that
establishes a series of sanctions for
Colombia. The case has a sentence that we
have handed down last year. Bedoya Lima
versus Colombia.
raped
tortured and then abandoned
when she was covering news of
high public interest the court develops
the concepts of freedom of expression and
protection of journalists in relation
to in this case a woman who practices
this profession the men says bedoya
do not want to exercise our  voices and neither
want our points of view  view
and it is pointed out that violence against
journalists has a intimidating effect
reinforced when these attacks remain
in impunity among other possible
effects violence against women
journalists and the subsequent impunity
may discourage them from
continuing their political career or
working on certain issues and  We must
constantly say that there are cases
of violence against journalists, it is
precisely the question of the
intimidating effect, either through
direct censorship or through imposing
fear on other people who
practice journalism
on a very important issue.  attention
between freedom of expression and the right to
honor in this case the court established
in what is called the triplet is the
need for a limitation to
preserve the right to honor that
freedom of expression must respond to
the principles of legality and legitimate
necessity and necessity of a
democratic society this issue to the court  I take
in the case words irrutia verses
Ecuador of 2021 that it is the
complaint of the president of the republic
of Ecuador at that time in front of a
journalist and or grove still brought me a
newspaper the universe about the publication
of an article that entered people who
understood insulting  the court to analyze
the case was obtained in the case of
speech protected by its
public interest such as those referring to
behaviors is public officials in
exercise of their functions the
punitive response of the state through
criminal law is not conventionally precedent
reiterated that civil sanctions must
be  proportional to addressing to
prepare the damage suffered to the response
plaintiff reputation and not to silence or
punish critics of the government the
court warns about the university to
dictate anti-lab measures to prevent
journalists
from being harassed through successive
lawsuits  civil or criminal order and the
court
addressed the issue of plurality  of
communication media specifically on the
rights of indigenous peoples in the
Maya Kaqchikel case of is a ruling and
others versus Guatemala I do not want to go
into details of this but the court
stresses the importance of community radio stations
specifically with respect to indigenous peoples
it is enshrined  established the subtraction the
restoration of the law the
adequacy of internal law with the
annulment of convictions and
the training of the cee to
public officials so as not to continue
committing violations of human rights
I want to
conclude
words by making a general reflection
and it has to do with  what the sayings of
the profession had valence when he
presented me
I believe that the world
is in an instance in which
the so-called three of
democracy, human rights and
sustainable development are necessary, the rule of law
becomes an imperative need in a
continent that  is seriously
questioned by  authoritarianisms and
the emergence of trends that tend
to distort the rule of law and
corrupt democracy to violate the
eb's doing it and it seems to me that this
really is the great challenge we have
at this time and the jurisprudence of
the Inter-American Court of
Human Rights  what it does is determine
standard parameters that through
an institution called the
institute called
conventionality control that causes the
sentence to be handed down by the
inter-American court can be used or
should be used as parameters for
the purposes of deciding internal conflicts
by the national judges then all
this jurisprudence that this generates
all these positions of a
broad vision with a progressive sense with
a biological sense
based on the ultimate foundation of
human rights that human dignity
plays a fundamental role it did
throughout 42  years of existence of the
inter-American court and in these times
Difficult times that Kobe is experiencing today 19
economic crisis now an external war that
is hitting the entire region very hard,
especially the
most vulnerable sectors in the work of the
Inter-American Court, it is
especially
necessary in terms of the affirmation of the
rule of law  to the
filming of
representative democracy and to the guarantee
that human rights are not
empty paper but are a reality
throughout the continent thank you very much but
open to any questions that may be
asked
thank you very much Mr. Pérez Manrique
I think that now they are going  let's see questions but
I have a couple to start our
discussion
on the subject of freedom of
expression if you are willing to
comment I
can talk a little about what
you think is the responsibility of
private companies in social networks
for example facebook moving forward
freedom of expression we
all know that facebook has decided
that  It will follow the
domestic restrictions of countries such as Vietnam,
what kind of responsibility do these
companies have to protect
international rights in this area?
I believe that
companies
of this type that are
global in nature and act with a kind of
handicap in their favor or  advantage in its
favor in the sense of the defects it
has in global governance and the non-
existence of an authority that imposes
the rules of the rule of law in the
framework of its activities. I believe that here there
is a very important responsibility
on the part of the companies  but I believe that
one must move forward to overcome a
dichotomy in this sense, that is, at one
point because it is the tendency that we all
have to preserve freedom of
expression, there was talk of the possibility of
self-regulation,
today the pendulum was swinging towards
regulation by a  regulation that
can only be imposed from a state
because there cannot be globally due to
that deficiency of governance  global ance
an instance such as the
international court that can regulate
this so what I think we have to
go to a system in which these
companies have to agree to give
participation to the public give
participation to those who are
interested and express themselves through  of
the networks and not generate situations
of censorship because what do these
companies cause when they block certain
content that is ultimately
left to a decision that has a
business nature that does not have
other types of, that is, even though
it may have an altruistic purpose, let's say  This
is how it is when it is decided to subscribe to a
certain content of violence. For
example, the reality should be that there
would have to be an
unsuspected and
impartial authority or instance that could determine
clear rules of the game. I think that this is the great
challenge facing humanity today.
because this is a challenge sorry
save me I expanded with the time
we have  But I think that challenge
should be, let's say,
faced on the basis that not
only we, not only the public,
we as consumers,
consumers of networks, are interested
in clear rules of the rule of law,
but if companies don't don't do
n't don't join  to that position and
they set clear and legally correct rules for us
and together they run the risk of
disappearing because it loses there is a
risk of losing credibility on the one
hand becoming a bin of blue
then for example this system that
Facebook has that has like this
internal court  that they are deciding, that
is, what kind of actions they are going to take
to protect the rights of expression
of freedom of expression, it does not seem to you
that this is enough, I think that it is not
enough, I think that it is an attempt at
self-regulation,
but the issue is
like  we build that the judicial systems are
the judicial systems in the
world and the judicial systems at a
regional level such as the col  Little in America
we are powers against the majority,
so where is the power against
the majority of companies of this
type in hiring brilliant experts in
the world who abide by certain
rules or in which someone, for example, the name
of the users, can really
exercise the possibility  of some kind of
possibility of pressure, let's say in the
good sense of the words of a
negotiation to establish clear and democratic rules of the game,
another question and then I open it to the
audience, I could reflect a little
on the unique role
of the courts  regional courts, that is, in
comparison with the international system,
which is the only
important contribution of those
regional courts,
very interesting, the other, well, very
interesting, but it is very interesting,
I understand the following: if we take
the document that perhaps in recent
years has had a  greater
international support that are the
development goals  sustainable development of 2030 there
we have that one of the postulated
objectives 16 is to
expand access to justice and the
creation of fair and
inclusive societies that are accountable and a
fundamental element of the promotion of the
rule of law both nationally
and internationally,
I believe  that the national courts, the
regional courts, and I am talking
about our court, I am talking about the
European court of human rights, and
I am talking about the African courts of
human and peoples' rights,
constitute part of an essential rule of
law at the regional level
and constitute that possibility of  have
decisions from a
body that has the support of the
consensus of all the states,
that is to say, the right in a specific case
and in some cases to execute its
sentences, the essence of the definition
of the jurisdictional function, that is to
say, the right executes the  People I think
that this is the fundamental role of
the courts  regional I think they are
more necessary than ever I think that when
we see that beyond what we
know there are states that have
abandoned the system because they have not
withstood a series of sentences that the
system has imposed on them then
they prefer to say the sentences hurt
today sir you are  That
's me
now if I come back now we didn't
listen to the last 10 seconds oh
well he left some perfect ones thank you I
say where we are after 42 years
of work in the inter-American court that is
to say
let's think about freedom of expression that
what we have seen let's think about justice
transitional let's think about
issues such as the environment, which we
already have a constructive opinion
on the subject
in all the issues that the court addressed
has consolidated an index, let's
say, of standards that conventionality control channels
have a great
internal diffusion of the states so
I think  that this fundamental role of the court
in what I personally felt
when I assumed the presidency  In attendance at the court
in February of this year, I said that the great
challenge we had in the face of all
these difficulties and problems
is to strengthen this court in a good way,
that is, in the sense that
it is a court that has an arrival and with
them we have  a
very broad communication policy we are
returning to visits to the countries
we are trying to ensure that the supervision
of compliance existence is
closer helping the states taking
the victim to a local court
a court that is made of flesh and
blood that  That people get to know the
court, get to know what the court does,
get to know its judges, and
see it as the
last guarantee against
human rights violations. Thank you
very much, or we have several
questions here.  I am going to read the first one,
how the pandemic affected the right to
access information from the
first question,
undoubtedly the pandemic
generated an information policy  Confirmation
reserved
contrary to the principle that
all public opinion information
is open and exceptionally
reserved when certain
conditions are met today we continue to ignore
due to confidentiality agreements
how many vaccines our
governments bought at what price they paid us
etc etc etc and also in many
places
the pretext of pandemics was used
to restrict freedom of
expression, of course, although the reason
for the health workers may be a reason
that justifies certain limitations in certain cases,
as
the convention itself says, this cannot be
for an indefinite period of time nor can it  be
unlimited so if you cover the
question for me I answer
effectively freedom of
information was affected there were restrictions in many
countries on access to information and
some
existed then this is a problem
that we must attend to very carefully and
that I warn and with these terms the
response  Given that on April 9, 2020, the
court issued a statement
called Kobe and Human Rights
urging that the rule of law and
representative democracy
together with the guarantee of
human rights be the framework to undertake the
fight against the  pandemic and there
expressly reserved the
guarantee of freedom of expression and
to guarantee
investigative journalism as a
fundamental element to clear up doubts regarding
the pandemic because we have to on the one
hand what the states have restricted
but on the other hand there is  It is a very
interesting topic that one day we will see what to
study, what are the restrictions that I
saw that
the anti-donor groups and
vaccines in the region suffered to their freedom of expression and there is a
serious restriction of rights that this
is a very topic I am in the  framework the
university is a very interesting topic
that at some point investigative journalism is done
if it is a topic for the first time
I hear it so it's very interesting
here we have another question what happens
when a regional court issues a
sentence and the state does not comply how to get
states to comply with
sentences is a general problem for
international courts and tribunals
we are  say us in the
inter-American court has a very
particular system because in reality what the
American convention provides is by
article 65 that in the event that a
state fails to comply in a manner with the
ruling of the inter-American court,
notify the general assembly of the
oas  so that at the level of the policy of the
internal side of the eu adopt measures
with respect to that state that does not comply with the
court sentences
that on the one hand
is a strength but it
is also a weakness because there is a
quantity of non-compliance that can  being
left by the way what is the
reality the reality is that
beyond states that are put in
explanation of  contempt and they say I
will not comply at this time there is
only one state that says it will not
comply with a court sentence in the
region all the other states seek in their own
way to comply with the
court sentence the court sentence are
complex, they are structural
and there is, but there is, as I am going to say, there is no
100% non-compliance and if there is a non-
compliance, compliance by parts and
in the compliance supervision stage
that we want to do also in this
closeness a stage with the court going to
the countries talking  With the governments
talking to the victims, at this stage
progress is made and the
successive reparation measures that the
court has declared are being fulfilled, that is, this is a
process of permanent construction and
construction, among other things, of
court units such as the  court
of justice on human rights
thank you very much
there is another one is in general how do you see the
situation of freedom of expression in
the region what s  With the challenges
of freedom of expression in the region
that suffers from the ups and downs of the political situation,
there are governments
that guarantee the rules of the game' and
where anyone can express themselves and there are
governments in which restrictions are applied
and here I want to point out something
that  It is very important because
when I talk to people linked to
freedom of expression,
in fact, I work in many
UNESCO training activities on the subject of
freedom of expression and I say that
[Music]
freedom of expression has a great
ally in the jurisprudence of  the
Inter-American Court and that this jurisprudence
of the Inter-American Court
should be
raised
before national judges
because there is an obligation to control
conventionality so that they act
in accordance with the parameters of
human rights in terms of freedom of
expression without a doubt there are
governments  those who are not interested in
freedom of expression, there are governments that
The criticism not only
hurts them but it is intolerable and there
we have serious problems to open this
expression but it always remains and we see
these last three cases that
the court has resolved on freedom of expression that
really are extreme cases but that
nevertheless in the future  of time
motivated a decision that will be useful
or only for the specific case but for the
rest of the countries in the region thank you very much
another question if the journalist has an
essential role for freedom of
expression who thinks about the
murders and persecutions  that
religion in the region is increasing year by year, I
want to point out that
[Music]
this year we are celebrating the 20th anniversary of
the UNESCO declaration on the
protection of crimes against
journalists
on November 2, which is the day
of the  of nonviolence our
journalist on the fight against this
violence
will analyze the results
of that document, undoubtedly the
violence  physical to death the attack
against personal integrity is at one
extreme but there is daily violence
that has to do with the pressures that
have to do with threats and
if threats are not dealt with properly
they later become
concrete facts that is what  The
court in the case of line 292 has already said that
the anti-area was threatened until one
day they kidnapped her, she was kidnapped for two
months, once by the paramilitary gang
and another time by the guerrillas, so this this this
is demonstrating the
need for  One, as the
court says, is reinforced protection
for people who practice journalism
and special attention that the state should
have in these cases, and the court has said
that whenever a crime
against a journalist is reported, one
of the hypotheses is mandatory.  of
investigation has to be the role or the
function or the task that the journalist
fulfills as such then yes because it
always means there is an essential  to one is
is a potentially dangerous job
that should be a special protection
because it is on the other side of all
this violence what is the other side
of this violence is impunity
does not exceed
does not exceed 10% of the cases that have been
clarified  violence against journalists
and this is a phenomenon that is not from the
regions of the world the figures of the world
that have been accident I think that since 1997 they
say that the rate of clarification
of crimes against journalists is very
low
it is practically in a light they are
practically nil  In the cases in
which it is effectively possible to punish
the masterminds of these
crimes, the
most that has been possible to reach is the
hitmen who have caused the
deaths or injuries or whatever,
but not the masterminds  of
these crimes
what happens when a country and the court
disagree on whether or not a country has
complied with its obligation in
response to u  In a court ruling, it does not
wonder when a nation
explicitly rejects it, but when there is no
agreement on whether its obligations have been fulfilled,
well, in that case,
a dispute is generated, that is, within a
state case, it says I comply with this
measure and  The court understands that this has not been
complied with, this
is much more common than it may
seem.
Generally, the chord opts in
these cases to
develop on a justified basis because it understands
that it has not been complied with and by
specifically stating these these aspects revealed
that they lack compliance as  the
measures lack several compliances, they
give us how the measures are sometimes
complex, a debate is generated about this and
this
the court resolves them taking into
account all the opinions
many times, for example, to verify
compliance with a certain
measure, it is necessary to make visits to the state
in  question to directly verify a
factual situation
and this but this is being resolved within the
framework of the pr  Occess of monitoring
compliance with sentences
ok we have one more question from the
audience then I have one
more question and then he passed it to claudia the
last question from the audience is what is the
relationship between freedom of
expression and disinformation it is good that
people  Say what you think, even if
it is with false information.
Well, the issue is the
risks of censorship. I
repeat this in censorship, prior
censorship is absolutely prohibited
insofar as I believe that the great
function, the great challenge that
journalism has  Seriously, gentlemen,
professional journalism is
to dismantle these
false information campaigns through what is
called factual journalism and this is
one of the great challenges we have
today because we see how
certain lies sometimes go viral, that is,
I repeat myself because I have agreed
quite shocked that the issue of
vaccines is not, it is how it was created,
and it reached
a sector i
The idea that vaccines are
bad, harmful actions, etc., is important and relevant to people,
and so on, and this was advanced, for
example, in this case through the
creation of scientific evidence and the
creation of evidence that resulted
from what the results were between  the
people who were vaccinated and those who were
not, for example, this is a case but it
must be admitted and I repeat it again is what
I said today that in the social networks
facebook twitter in short
it really becomes an engine for
a series of things that are  undesirables
that are not really a debate but
that everyone who sounds networks believes
that it is due to the truth and thinks that what they
say is an absolute truth and
then there is no possible debate in that
sense through the networks and I think
there is  pay special attention to
this
and we all know what bots are,
trolls and all the things that can be
done by manipulating the opinion
of people and manipulating the
profession  sion there is one in the world of
networks has inspired a word that is
tremendous that we call truth, that
is, in opposition to the truth and a
truth that is something like
the truth that they think
exists regarding a certain situation and they
intend to impose on  the others, then
these are the great challenges of
modern society and I believe that we
must act freely but that we must
also act responsibly and I
repeat once again the great role played by
not only these large companies
but also the media, whether digital or
through the common ways of doing
serious journalism,
investigative journalism and journalism based on
facts,
because there are so many thanks. Well,
before I thank you for your
generosity in spending this time with
us, I want to ask you one
last question and ask you to make some
reflections.  there are many about the
international human rights system here in the usa
and there is no difference among students
and faculty  You are speaking at the universities
about this international
human rights system and I wanted to know if you
have any thoughts on the
next phase of the system or areas of
reform that are needed. Well,
first of all,
it is worrying
that the United States
this tour supports the great documents
of the universal system, but
The great document of the
universal system but for example it is
outside the American convention
and we do not have it as an ally as a
member of the system we know what
reasons
are important in short but I would like to
move in the US integrated into the region and
with concrete commitments regarding  of
human rights from the legal point of view
that is a first reflection the
second reflection is that I believe that
beyond this attitude of the usa as a nation
there is an attitude of the academic world
that is very important an attitude
of many journalists in the usa  very
important that has to do with
this question of spreading what the
system does in  inter-American system and how to take
standards of the inter-American system
as a basic rule or a
party rule, a starting point to judge
certain situations I believe that the
inter-American system requires
modifications and I have said that I believe in
direct access to the court, that is, it
has what  What was seen in Europe that this is
a Europe that first there was a
commission that filtered the cases that
came to the European court because it was
the only one that could present cases before
the court as in the
inter-American commission in the only one that can
present a case before the court I think  that
they have to be reviewed, I think
that the
systems of the supervision of sentences have to be fine-tuned, that
they have to be given greater solidity, that
the court has to be given
better possibilities to work in the
supervision of sentences, and I think that the
system has  to fulfill a vocation
of universality, for example,
by extending to the
speaking area of ​​the Caribbean where h  There are few
countries that are within the system
to make the system attractive to those
Caribbean countries and why not think
that somehow
all we are in is
public law, we have added and studied and
carefully follow what the
US Supreme Court says and  What the
North American courts say
would be constitutional because not being able to
think of a common god is that it
allows us to unite and allows this
power to work horizontally through
common courts
because, well, thank you very much Mr.
Pérez Manrique for spending this time with
us and your  generosity in sharing
your opinions and thoughts and
many thanks to the audience, he
passes it on to claudia to pass this
conversation on but it is also
my turn to thank Mr. pérez
manrique for sharing his years of
experience and mainly for
sharing his current vision
of the  human rights in Latin America
in particular I rescue what he said to the
subtel in the last  imo minute on trying
to incorporate Caribbean-speaking countries
which I know would be a good
move to generate more
community feeling in the court and I also
thank Professor Claudia Flores
for her excellent moderation her
excellent questions
moved the dialogue up a notch  very
productive way and finally to the audience
for also contributing with questions that
made this dialogue meaningful and I
invite you to continue participating in this
series and thank you very much to all
of you thank you
very much until next time thank you very much